SUBJECT: I think, for
me, being outside,
there's always been
some connection.
I don't want to be on my phone.
I don't like being in
front of a computer screen.
I like being outside,
and the trees,
and I just feel really at
ease and very happy out there.
The hardest part
about tree climbing
is definitely getting
the rope in the tree.
As I'm walking
through the forest,
I'm kind of scoping out the
different trees looking,
how tall they are, and if
there's good branches to climb.
And once I find a nice candidate
tree, I'll get my slingshot,
and I'll shoot a line over.
It's given me a lot
of opportunities,
not just with science,
but also with television.
People want to be able
to film in the canopies.
So I can do rigging for that.
It's also allowed me to
travel around the world.
I've worked in Borneo.
I've worked in Africa.
I've worked in central
South America and Europe.
So there's classes
around the world
you can take that will
teach you how to efficiently
and safely get into the canopy.
I didn't take them.
I was drunk in a bar in Panama.
So I just bribed somebody $40.
They showed me how to
do it in 10 minutes.
It's really easy.
You have to understand
the equipment
and constantly monitor
the usage of it.
So you want to make sure
everything's really safe.
You want to protect your ropes
because every single piece
that I have is mission critical.
If one piece breaks,
I fall and die.
So it's very important to
really inspect your stuff.
The most common reaction I
get when I'm on a flight,
sitting next to somebody,
and they ask what do I do,
and I tell them I study sleep
in sloths, and I climb trees,
they think it's a joke.
And then I tell them,
no, I'm serious.
And I show them
pictures on my phone,
and they're like, that is the
coolest job I've ever heard of.
And how is that really job,
and how do I get to do that?
INTERVIEWER: What
do you tell them?
SUBJECT: I tell them to
go to bars in Panama.
I think it's
important that people
realize they can do whatever
the heck they want to.
So don't just accept
the fact that I'm
going to have an
office job, and boring.
No.
Do something fun.
You only live once.
Do something awesome.
Once you get 5, 10,15 feet
up, it's really nice and calm.
And you kind of sit down for
a second and look around,
and it's really beautiful.
It's really peaceful.
I think people climb
a tree, it makes
some sort of tangible connection
between them and the outdoors.
It's not just
walking on a trail,
or seeing a picture,
or something.
But actually physically
getting involved in climbing
and the motion of that
is a powerful thing.
NARRATOR: Please check
out this next video.
SUBJECT: I first started
experimenting with taxidermy
when I was a little kid.
People sometimes
think it's creepy.
I don't think it's
creepy at all.
NARRATOR: Thanks for watching.
Please subscribe
to secret stories,
so you can see new
videos every week.